yeah and i think uh what you said
earlier about kind of that fomo is an
interesting point because what we've
seen traditionally and what i think
we're seeing now is that the media comes
in right the price starts to appreciate
the media comes in and they flood
everyone with a bunch of information on
bitcoin right you see it everywhere you
can get it whether it's on cnbc or any
of these other networks and then that's
where you get all the retail
participation of people for mowing in
saying hey i don't want to miss this
price action there's an opportunity for
it to really appreciate so as an example
like just today right you were on cnbc
talking about bitcoin price action and
the lightning network subsac announced
500 000 users they were enabling bitcoin
payments for on their platform ftx
announced the 20 million dollar naming
rights deal with a college stadium of
which they paid 100 in crypto uh and
then what we saw uh block fi last week
signed signed a deal with the number one
overall draft pick right so like even
just today in the past couple days
there's been a bunch of announcements
visa bought a crypto punk right so like
there's a bunch of things that come in
because these companies realize this is
their opportunity to go out and market
all this stuff right it's so marketing
is one big piece of it right like talk
about visa buying a crypto punk like 150
000 for a visa doesn't matter they're
not trying to make money on 150 000
investment but what it does is it
continues to show that there are some
companies that realize this is the
future and they're going to go lean into
this pretty heavy and they're going to
embrace it and they understand
bitcoin is the future cryptocurrencies
are the future digital technologies are
the future then there's companies who
are literally never going to embrace
this stuff right we talked about last
week we literally held a funeral for
western union those guys are done ko
there's no way that they're going to
adopt bitcoin right and so when you
start to think about the difference in
response
you can't prevent innovation from
happening but you can control how you
respond to it and i think that's what
we're ultimately seeing is look at visa
versus western union visa already is
doing things with bitcoin stable coins
now they got the crypto punk thing like
they are trying to figure it out maybe
they're successful maybe they're not
right there's a guy over there kai
sheffield who's doing a fantastic job uh
kind of running all of this and he
really understands it but can he get the
big organization to embrace it and kind
of go all in we'll see
but western union they can't even keep
their service up for people in
afghanistan right and so i think you're
just seeing two completely different
approaches but it ultimately goes back
to the idea uh remember there are not
that many companies right now that have
bitcoin on their balance sheet right if
you look at that list outside of the
crypto businesses what there's like five
companies i could think of microstrategy
tesla square uh and then you've got that
biotech company so four companies
actually the uh the biotech company last
week that announced and outside of
microstrategy non-crypto businesses yeah
and none of them are really like a
substantial portion right i mean micro
strategies obviously spent a bunch of
money on it but tesla it's like a couple
percentage points square it's a little
bit right like so there's no uh one
person that has gone out and made that
concentrated bet like michael saylor has
when this thing starts
you you'll watch the show and you'll
just hear us say yup
we're in the fomo phase cause it's gonna
happen i don't know when it starts to
happen but it'll slowly build up and
then there's going to be like a two
three week period where literally
you're gonna literally try to go to
sleep at night and you're not gonna be
able to go to sleep because you can't
stop thinking about what's happening
you're gonna wake up and pick what i
miss and it's just going to be every
single person in your life is going to
be talking about this the uber driver
your barber your friend your mom
everyone is going to be talking about
this stuff and when you feel that that's
when you know okay we're starting to hit
that fomo phase but if we go back and
look at the fomo phase of 2017 and other
bull markets
it supersedes almost everyone's
expectations and what we're talking
about now is in the heart of a bull
market we had a 50 plus percent drawdown
the volatility on this thing is unlike
any other asset and so when you start
thinking about all of these wall street
guys that come in right whether they're
hedge funds whether they're corporations
whether they're uh some sort of asset
manager i don't think they're ready for
this like this stuff is going to
absolutely rip their faces off and you
see it with a guy like michael burry
listen michael berry gets all the credit
in the world we talked about last week
for the housing short
he gets zero credit for going around
running around yelling and screaming
about head and shoulders head and
shoulders bitcoins going down right if
you look at uh what's the guy um scott
minard or whatever right he the cio he
was saying that bitcoin could trade as
low as like 15 000 20 000 or whatever
and it turns around and just rips
people's faces off and i think that's
what people have to understand if you
are an investor not only do you have to
do your own research not only should you
be uh kind of sizing a position
correctly in your portfolio all those
timeless investing principles you also
have to understand this is a highly
highly highly volatile asset volatility
is not good or bad volatility is bad if
it goes against you if i'm long bitcoin
and it goes down that's bad volatility
if i'm long bitcoin and it goes up
that's good volatility so volatility not
good or bad it just depends on whether
it goes with you or against you but
please please please make sure that you
understand when volatility occurs it
leads to all sorts of human emotion
everything from fear to greed etc and
that's ultimately what we see play out
in these fomo cycles is 80 of bitcoin
not moving in six months and all of a
sudden new demand comes in i don't know
i don't want to say where i think the
price is going but it's going much much
much higher than where it is right hey
guys thanks so much for watching that
clip of the best business show make sure
you like and subscribe to the channel
turn on notifications so you know when
we go live every weekday and then head
to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it